the trans movement is targeting
Christians including with violence that
is wrong most Christian leaders in this
country don't want to admit that
admitting it might force them to take
deeply unfashionable positions but it is
true and anyone who's paying attention
knows that it's true and so like most
true things at this point it is
officially suppressed now that is also
part of the story
part of getting your audience to believe
insane untrue things
is priming them that the reason they
might not hear this insane untrue thing
elsewhere isn't because it's untrue it's
because it's being suppressed elsewhere
which of course it's not that the trans
movements Vendetta against Christianity
is being suppressed it's that it doesn't
exist
anywhere Beyond resentment over those
who weaponize their Christian faith
against trans people